no they're never just boltons
it's all part of history it's all part
of the world's history
majority of people don't know we're here
the facility it's custom made to build
dinosaurs
my name is peter may and i build
dinosaur skeletons for museums
throughout the world
i'm the owner president of research
casting international we have 50 000
square feet we can handle the biggest
skeletons in the world
t-rex mastodons
allosaurs
we've mounted and displayed and built
right around 800 skeletons
in our back room we have 50 skeletons
sitting in crates
when the skeleton arrives it'll be
uncreated unpacked and then it'll go
into the conservation department it'll
be cleaned and hardened and any of the
old consultants removed so it's nice and
strong
it comes to blacksmiths they hammer out
the armatures once all the armatures are
done then we go to mounting
all in all they'll probably be about a
crew of 10 that'll handle the
fossils the car i saw the skeleton crew
we're doing a pair of skeletons right
now the driptasaurs and they're probably
one of the most dynamic poses you'll
ever see there's two dryptosaurs like
leaping in the air one on his back one
leaping down on top of it
we built the two big skeletons in the
first movie jurassic park the the
rearing barrisser at the american museum
of natural history
for the smithsonian we're helping them
rebuild all their exhibits all the
fossil animal exhibits
our job is to bring the old skeletons to
life
i think when fossils arrive here we
become the caretaker nothing can happen
to it and every person is handled along
the way understands that responsibility
by the time it's finished it comes out a
much better
fossil than when it arrived when it goes
on exhibit at the museum it's going to
last for another 100 years
you